we go back to parkland Phil kitty now
has his a guest
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi who
we just heard from in that press
conference Phil I don't think the
Attorney General can hear me if she
could go into this whole aspect of a
social media imprint what some of these
shooters are saying online are we
capturing enough of this are we paying
enough attention to that all right Sean
the first thing wants to be asked you
before we get to what you said with
President Trump today is social media
and what some of these killers and
accused killers in these mass murders
and shooting sprees are posting or
hinting at or alluding to what can we do
about that from a law enforcement
perspective well first of all any you
know when they're posting and on social
media they have followers so kids are
out there parents you've got to monitor
this stuff and if you see it take
everything seriously take every threat
seriously and report it to law
enforcement we would rather you do that
and be wrong 99% of the time then have
anything happen in this world and and
these teams now are vocal on social
media they don't just pop up from
anywhere there are warning signs and if
you see warning signs with your child if
you know some of your kids friends who
you feel you need to report it you need
to go to school counselors you need to
let people know that that something
isn't right last summer you settled so
much time of an Orlando for the pulse
nightclub shooting how sickened were you
today when suddenly you got the call
it's happened to you again at another
school here in your state it was
heartbreaking and in fact when I was on
immediately I came down here but on my
way down I also went to Las Vegas when
they had the mass shooting at the
concert out there and one of the victims
that I still keep in touch with she has
a bullet lodged in her spine she
contacted me on my way down and was
still so traumatized crying saying that
she's still praying for the victims here
so this is really the third time and
we've partnered with the great men and
women
of the FBI who are victims advocates
with mine and we're working just to get
these families through this to get them
the counseling the help they need and to
not be taken advantage of believe it or
not by bad people during this time and
Shawn you have one more thing more
question for the Attorney General
attorney general Bondi has been known
for a really tough law and order
Attorney General in the state of Florida
my question is if we can't monitor evil
that's in people's hearts is it time
what about retired military retired
police in every school at least have
some front line of defense to give some
capacity to to stop carnage when it
starts like this as an aggressive law
enforcer and the chief law enforcement
officer in the state of Florida the
fourth most populous kind of state of
the country third actually passed New
York
so is it feasible and is it plausible
and should we do it start having armed
guards at every single school and if not
armed guards you have perhaps retired
military retired law enforcement to
provide a beefier scenario in and around
schools as a form of deterrent yeah I
was a career prosecutor I firmly agree
with that yes that's why we have school
resource officers do they need more help
yes do I see of course if we have the
funding for it I think we do I think we
need that now that's what we're seeing
around this world and we have to protect
our kids from these monsters you know
President Trump called me tonight and we
talked at length he is heartbroken he is
praying for all these families all he
wanted to ask me how are the families
how are the families how are the
families and that's where I'm headed now
to do my job as Attorney General and
with my advocates provide counseling
funeral expenses
and mental health counseling for all
these traumatized victims as well you
know President Trump is scheduled to be
in Orlando on Friday afternoon that make
his way to Mara Lago for the weekend in
light of this did he indicate whether he
would also be making a visit down here
you know all we talked about all his
only concern tonight the victims as it
should be all he asked about what how
are the victims how are the victims are
they okay how are the families he was so
worried about the families and the
victims you know he's a father he's a
grandfather and he deeply deeply cares
about what's happening down here and
Grenda we are very early into the
prosecution of this case but clearly
he's 19 years old he is eligible for the
death penalty eligible for full
convictions on murder multiple counts
and life in prison any personal feelings
as to what you would like to see your
state attorney pursue well you're
talking to a career prosecutor who seeks
death penalty who's prosecuted death
penalty cases again we don't know the
aggravators and the mitigators we don't
know the mental health and out but when
you kill that amount of people surely
this would be a death penalty especially
when it seems so pre-planned and pre
designed with pulling of the fire alarm
I can't talk about the facts now but but
given what I know I would firmly believe
it would be a death penalty case of
course Attorney General Pam Bondi thank
you very much for joining us here and
Shawn one last thing that the governor
did say one to recap he said you know as
a grandparent a parent you see this on
the news you wonder oh my gosh could
this happen to me and when you see it
happen again your heart sinks and his
conclusion was the only thing you can
conclude here tonight this man this
suspect is nothing but pure evil right
Phil thank you and the Attorney General
thank you